il était le plus agréable mais dans une
promenade à travers paraît en tout qui
était être des planer dans les quartiers
les plus fréquentés de la capitale mais
ne boudez rue isolée où le suiveur
d'allant vos quêtes dans l'oeuvre pour
vous surprendre et vous poursuivre
obstinément de ces propos outrageants
on
pour éviter ceci apprenez vous
débarrasser du gêneur par quelques
places pas celle de gilot selon monsieur
vos attaques par derrière on est le
gentiment par la taille et basculé
lentement si on contre arrive aux
attaques de pas s'en lasser le
franchement puis d'un simple
déhanchements autour d'îlots sur le
trottoir s'il ne suit vous attaque de
biais d'un simple coup de poing en lui
plaquant les pieds boulet taille est le
plus dangereux est certaine le preneur
et d'ayants l'air de rien se laisse
dépasser pour nouveau saisir au vol pour
celui-ci n'attendit pas à tacler
aussitôt aussi le se départir à celle